I'm competing with my job often on the
other side of what you're afraid of that
you experience really great things it's
so hard to to say no to stuff I think
you always want to be challenging
yourself and pushing yourself in the
work that you do because that's how you
experience those situations what's the
impediment to action advance is actually
what stands in the way it comes away I
try to think about this in my own life
hello believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet so to help you
on your journey today we're going to
learn from author marketer and
entrepreneur Ryan holiday and my take on
his top ten rules for success volume 2
rule number 8 is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best also as you're watching if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired by it as
well and if you leave it within the
first couple hours of this video going
live you have a chance to win one of two
daily prizes
I would rather challenge myself in my
career than challenge myself on a
rollercoaster which is totally pointless
and I would rather like for instance I
love running
I run almost every single day but I
don't do any races I don't feel the need
to have artificial competition in my
life like I'm competing with my job do
you know I was like I'm trying to write
the best I'm trying to challenge myself
with my writing running for me is
something I enjoy and to me that the
challenge is like oh can I do it every
day not like did I beat 200 other people
who I barely hear about well I think the
point for the one thing that you've
added is like I think sometimes we have
like these artificial expectations that
are necessary yes right you're like hey
I don't run because I enjoy running yeah
I'm not trying to be competitive and
I've been for your writing like you are
competitive but with yourself I think it
being present and enjoying what happened
is is is important I guess what I'm
saying is like like yesterday I ran I
did an hour and it was you know 92 or 93
degrees outside
it was hot right like and and but I
didn't say like hey do I is this gonna
be enjoyable or not I said look this is
what I do and come hell or high water
I'm gonna do it you know and and and and
it was enjoy I got it wasn't enjoyable
at first but I but I pushed through that
it's like on the other side of that
resistance is often that thing and so I
think that's the problem with people who
are like you know I'll just sort of go
with the flow I'll take it as it happens
that can work but you know it's often on
the other side of what you're afraid of
that you experience really great things
and you have to have the power to push
through that why do you feel the most
satisfied doing and where do what do you
feel the most sort of fulfilled or
creative doing and then that's got to be
the sort of gift that you protect at all
times and then you've got to find beyond
the other things that you're either good
at and but you don't want to be doing or
you're really bad
take a lot of your time and you've got
to being able to delegate and find
services or companies or other people
that you can hire to help you with those
things and like that that's really
that's always been something I've
struggled with and I think is a sort of
perennial struggle of any kind of
leadership or entrepreneurship how do
you how do you build the organization or
the structure that you need so so you
can continue to do what you need to do
as the as the boss or as the main
creative force and you've got to be able
to to continually evaluate your own
performance in that sense and say like
look you know this is what I'm really
good at this is what I'm not good at
here's someone who's better at it than
me I'm I'm considering it an investment
to hire that person or to to bring on
that service provider and and and I'm
doing it so I can continue to be as good
as I need to be at at my my sort of core
thing it's 8 a.m. like I gotta get to
the office and I was like why like why
do I have to get like I I always wanted
to be a writer I accomplished this thing
I could make a living being a writer I
have a home like I haven't been there in
weeks like why am I here and and I was
like I was here because like I just said
yes I didn't think about like I mean I
didn't actually weigh like the pros and
cons of this scenario and again it's
like sometimes you got to do it you
don't want to do to figure out what you
want to do but it was like I I'd sort of
distance myself from a lot of things and
I've gotten it got my life in a good
place and then someone called me and
offered me money on the phone and I said
yes because it's so hard to say it like
it's so hard to to say notice stuff like
especially if you're like I do it's so
hard to say like I want to do this but I
also want to do that I have to choose
that's easy to say like I'm gonna try to
do both at the same time and I said yes
to both like I don't I don't think I've
ever like quit anything like I've just
added new stuff right and so for me
that's certain
has added up over time to an
unsustainable load we all wake up the
same every day we both wake up and
things don't go the way we're like
there's not just the University when
you're younger but there's also the
day-to-day reality it's like you run a
business and I run a business and you
know this this you have a problem with
your accounting software and then you
are having problems with with Skype this
morning right like there's also those
minor situations and how you choose to
deal with them determines whether you're
gonna have a good day or a bad day just
in the same way that other situations
determine whether you're gonna have a
good life or a bad life and how you
choose to respond like if you if you
know Skype wasn't working and if you
said like if you got mad you know if you
decided that this was horrible if you
got really frustrated it might not only
would that mess with your attitude but
then it doesn't help you with the
situation that you then have to deal
with which is okay how am I gonna find a
solution and how am I gonna do this
interview and how am I gonna get the
best out of it like I'm giving a talk
right let's say I'm giving a talk in
from an audience I don't control the
audience I don't control you know the
weather I don't control any of these
things but I do control what I bring to
that situation so I want to focus the
entirety of my energy on doing the best
possible job and salvaging the most out
of gear I think the big problem that
many people have is they don't know
what's important to them and so they end
up getting distracted by things that
other people are doing or things that
other people are trying to do to them
right and so like I like we're talking
about with my business early on I'm
thinking okay this is the way that
you're supposed to do things because
this is how everyone else runs their
business what I didn't stop to do is
think what kind of business do I want
and what kind of life am i trying to
have and when I was actually able to
have that conversation I was able to cut
out a bunch of extraneous things it
makes the most sense for my personal
happiness of my personal success to try
to make as much money as possible for
his least amount of time commitment as
possible so I can write as much as poss
well versus trying to you know make as
much money as possible however possible
right right and so sometimes you got to
do the wrong thing too like you got to
touch the stove and go like this is
really hot I don't want to do this ever
again right and so it's sort of pivoted
you know my business and it would like
they say like you know it's not a
principal till it cost you money like we
had it's one of the other partners went
off started a different company in his
made you know it's done very well for
himself and you know we've we've passed
on a lot of projects that went on to do
like pretty well and so like you you see
like there's a cost so like having the
life you want there's a cost right and
you gotta be ready to pay that cost and
the worst thing you can do is try to
have like try to have your cake and eat
it too right to try to have the life you
want about doing the things you don't it
just doesn't work I think you always
want to be challenging yourself and
pushing yourself in the work that you do
because that's how you experience those
situations you know it's very easy once
you get to a certain point to be to sort
of find your comfort zone and stay in it
and not be challenged that's not to say
that life won't visit challenges upon
you but you're gonna experience right um
but I think exercising and working out
is a great metaphor for this like I I
try to run every single day and I like I
don't care what the weather is
I don't care how I'm feeling it's
something I'm gonna subject myself to
and force myself to and you know often
I'll find like I run in the afternoons
for instance and I'll find that I'll be
tired that the day won't have gone very
well you know that maybe I wasn't
feeling great um but that hour that I'm
out there sweating when I when I come
back I'm ready to go again I've been
recharged and fun I think being able to
find that hey I do better when I'm
challenged is a great thing to teach
yourself and and and and the other thing
Tim Ferriss told me this he was saying
you know if you work out every single
day
you have a guaranteed win every single
day so your company might be declaring
bankruptcy but you you set a new PR
or you know you have you you know you
got a great rush of endorphins you'll at
least be able to tell yourself like hey
that went well and that's something that
that the reason I seek out that hardship
every day is that it's a hardship that
I'm sort of guaranteed to overcome as a
creative what the critics think of your
work what the audience thinks of your
work what gatekeepers or lists or a
category you know curators think of your
work these are the things that are
outside of your control and you have to
remind yourself of that and and as a
creative if you go into what you're
doing and you say I'm only gonna be
happy if this external thing happens
right I'm only gonna be happy if if it's
published by this publisher if I'm only
gonna be happy if it wins this award
it's only gonna be happy if I make this
amount of money these are recipes for
misery because you've now put your
happiness in the hands of someone else
someone who is indifferent to you
someone you don't control your you make
of it don't lose myself you make a
business decision or a choice and it
turns out to be a mistake you were
totally wrong you can you can see that
as a mistake and you can get down on
yourself where you can see it as a
chance to get comfortable with failure
because failure is a part of life where
a scientist doesn't get upset when a
hypothesis that they had turns out to be
wrong because it that's what they do
that's the whole point they're learning
each time they do something wrong or a
computer I'm sure as college students a
lot of you get this as well here you
spend weeks and weeks working on paper
and the computer deletes it right a
glitch erases the work that you've had
so you can go set you can do with what I
did the last time this happened to me
was you get so upset and you kick a
trash can across the room and it makes a
huge dent in the wall or you can see
this as a chance to to start over you
can see is a chance to now that you've
been through it once to do it again and
ultimately produce a piece of
this a higher quality than maybe you
originally intended to return it you can
you can use it the chance to actually
raise your standard rather than then
simply model through what's the
impediment to action advances actually
what stands in the way becomes the way I
try to think about this in my own life
whenever I'm facing any kind of
situation and I've yet to find one that
is it made better from this attitude
that isn't made better by seeing each
and every obstacle as a chance to
practice excellence and it's in its in a
new form and you know I think today we
all face our own problems there's tough
economic times we have a political
situation that's a you know we all face
individual obstacles as a daily basis
and we culturally face obstacles but we
have a chance to see those things like
vase on them which is to not only not
see them as bad but to see them as as
opportunities as as chances to improve
or to practice something that perhaps we
we otherwise wouldn't have practiced
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Garrett de asked
me to if there's someone you like me to
profile in their future top ten please
check out the link down in the
description below and you can cast your
vote on who we should do next I also
want to give a quick shredder to dave
Lucas from the misfit entrepreneur Dave
thank you so much for breaking up a copy
of my book your one word and taking that
awesome picture of you with the book at
the beach makes me jealous kind of want
to be there it makes it really good
Beach reading so thank you so much for
the support and posting it and I'm so
glad that you enjoyed the book thank you
guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope you can too need
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
[Music]
let's focus on what benefits are
inherent in any situation and let's not
focus on what we've been deprived on
because we can't what we control only
that attitude right and so we might as
well give ourselves the attitude that
pushes us forward that makes us feel
that that seizes on what we are
empowered to do and not dwell on what
we've been deprived of or or what is
holding us back I do think it's
interesting how we sort of expect like
my a few months ago I got injured and I
couldn't work out for like about a week
or so and it was like why did I think
that I could go my whole life without
being like why did I think that I would
never be injured right why did I think
it would I would all it with every time
I roll my ankle it would turn out to be
nothing do you know what I mean
sometimes it turns out to be something
and and and the more we can the more we
can tell ourselves that these are
realities of life the less devastated
will be when they happen and the more
quickly we can bounce back from them do
you know what I mean like if that if
someone does something rude or you know
screwed up to you and your why did this
happen this is so unfair how could they
do this to me and all you're doing is
wallowing in self-pity
you know that's precious energy that
you're not spending towards your you
know your reply towards your response or
what you're gonna do instead